so in the last video we started talking
about the system of jim crow segregation
which was a legal form of segregation
and denial of voting rights or
disenfranchisement which characterized
the american south from approximately
1877 to 1954. and we finished up by
saying that with the end of the civil
war the system of slavery which had been
the economic and political system which
characterized all of the south for the
200 plus years before the civil war and
we finished up by saying now that the
civil war has outlawed slavery in 1865
what is the south going to look like
without slavery
so in this video i want to really dial
in in this period
after the civil war known as
reconstruction now i don't have room
here to go into a great deal of detail
about the civil war we'll make many more
videos about that in the future but what
i do think is important to note about
the civil war is that for the united
states of america
uh often called the north
in the civil war
even though the civil war really didn't
start out as a war to end slavery by the
end of the civil war it had really
become a war to end slavery as northern
armies became in effect armies of
liberation in the south in 1863 abraham
lincoln
issued the emancipation proclamation
which ended slavery in all states that
were rebelling against the united states
and in 1865 the government ratified the
13th amendment
to the constitution
which outlawed slavery for good but all
the 13th amendment said was that you
couldn't have slavery it really didn't
say anything about what racist relations
between whites and blacks in the south
would be after the civil war or whether
not being a slave meant that an
african-american person in the south had
the full rights of citizenship that a
white person would have so in the
immediate aftermath of the civil war
states in the south began writing new
constitutions
to account for the end of slavery but
the white leaders in the south really
have no conception of a world where
african americans are equal to whites
and so the new laws that they write
regulating african americans after the
war are known as the black codes
and these black codes
are in many ways slavery by a different
name so the black codes acknowledge the
end of slavery and they give some basic
rights to african americans such as the
right to marry
which enslaved people could not legally
do under the system of slavery and the
right to own property
but that is pretty much it the black
codes did things like prevent african
americans from
owning firearms
from
being without a labor contract now
remember the south is based on these
cash crops like tobacco and cotton and
land owners are terrified that if all of
the former enslaved people leave the
south they're going to have nobody to
work in their fields nobody to harvest
these crops and their economic system is
going to plummet they're already in very
bad shape after the civil war so they
say all african americans have to be in
a labor contract
and these labor contracts were usually
very
um small wages for quite a bit of labor
and if they were not in a labor contract
or if they left in the middle of a year
say
then they were considered vagrants
and the most outrageous thing that these
southern governments do is say that
african americans cannot vote
now to people in the north
who had just fought a four-year-long war
where more than half a million people
died to end slavery seeing southern
states pass laws that are pretty much
slavery with another name was galling
and so the more radical republican
elements in congress these are members
of abraham lincoln's party who are
strongly abolitionist who are strongly
in favor of civil rights for african
americans and strongly in favor of a
strong central government say okay this
system of black codes is not okay when
we said slavery was over we didn't just
mean that you couldn't enslave someone
we also meant that african americans had
full citizenship rights in the south so
to combat the black codes congress
passes the 14th
amendment to the constitution
and the 14th amendment says that anyone
who is born in the united states
regardless of whether or not they were a
slave is a full citizen of the united
states eligible for all of the benefits
of citizenship and equal protection
under the law so laws must be equal for
whites and for blacks and we'll get into
what that means in the next video